can we get you a drink or something uh
you know what can i get a good burger
[Applause]
keenan thompson given the emmy's
audience what they want a reunion with
kell mitchell it'd be nice to like you
know humanize these folks a little bit
we'll find a way for that to be funny
hopefully why don't you just do one of
those fun little tom cruise and cocktail
tricks we talked okay yeah i've been
practicing here we go all right here we
go tom cruise
yeah the snl stars clearly having fun
hosting the 74th emmy awards they're
making me actually make everybody's
drinks
well you're the bartender honorary
honorary i didn't know i'd be doing an
eight-hour shift
and keenan's all smiles as he reunites
with a familiar face why don't you take
this guy's order over here excuse me sir
can we get you a drink or something uh
you know what can i get a good burger
[Applause]
this comes 25 years after keenan and
kell hit the big screen together
welcome to good burger home of the good
burger can i take your order
fast forward to 2022 keenan's may be
hinting at a second helping oh my
goodness let's do some kung fu while
they roll into the next package let's do
it
[Applause]
we should note keenan's been teasing a
follow-up all year are you saying that
good burger 2 is happening
i would like it to we are where we're
you know working harder on it than than
ever so it's like ed's character should
have like a million kids and then like
i'm coming out of jail for something
that he put
you know ed's kind of kind of like you
know kind of universal you know what i'm
saying you know he can dig with anything
good is good ain't it right that's why
we had good burger cause we the good
folks jump on the fry and then you hop
on the cup and then shimmy up the straw
what is this american gladiators come on
the duo's on-screen chemistry goes back
almost 30 years every week it's a new
challenge and we attack it everywhere
professional pride and still
and from the past to the future keenan's
gearing up for season 48 of saturday
night live which is set to introduce
audiences to a whole new crop of not
ready for prime time players you are the
longest running cast member on snl
correct you're losing seven people this
year when you're getting an influx of
new people what's the advice you give to
a newbie
it depends like i don't really just like
walk up and be like hey sit down new
person let me tell you like you know how
to do this kind of thing
but you know when they're rehearsing and
because everybody's experience is
different so i let them kind of just
experience things but when it comes to
rehearsing and i see things going kind
of left or right or i think a shot
should be different or like little
blocking little i'll suggest things that
i notice in the moment but past that
everybody's got to like dig through the
mud you know what i mean and figure it
out
[Music]
you